[Musique]
parce qu'une sculpture c'est d'abord de
la géométrie
angèle en juin sculpteur tréport
toujours d'un élan dans le kop exemple
de la ferrière jamais de ma vie je suis
parti d'une photo vous faire une oeuvre
mais là c'était trop évident
je me suis dit qu'un sculpture
monumentale il faut que je le fasse
j'étais en fait de travailler sur une
autre non terminée hélas pour ne pas
perdre le fil pour garder mon élan j'ai
pris la photo je les mises sur un mur et
tout les jours je les regardais je me
disais je vais le faire donc je n'ai pas
de contrat ça coûte quelque chose faire
une oeuvre comme ça des dix fils auteur
immense
maintenant on pense pas ça on dit on le
fait et ça va être tellement beau
tellement extraordinaire qui va y avoir
un agenda
vous remarquez que l'escalier sans voix
en oblique formats comme une pyramide
qui mène vers la paix du personnage ne
marche que je n'ai pas conçu en la
faisant c'était que dans ce sens là
aussi j'avais mis car droit s'il donnait
un air un peu hautain et après ça j'ai
penché de caen vers l'avant comme ceci
et je lui ai donné ce qu'on appelle un
mouvement il ne bouge pas mais il est en
mouvement vers nous c'est un homme
extraordinaire c'est dany laferrière 4
sillery
il a cinq ans c'est un enfant et quand
il est sérieux et d'une gravité
extraordinaire
donc j'ai enlevé par exemple les plis
qu'il y avait sur son front pour ne pas
lui donner un air toujours angoissé je
les monte sur sur des marches d'escalier
en oblique pour donner l'impression que
c'est comme un pharaon si on veut qu'un
homme qui a atteint un sommet mais
l'escalier et un fauteuil
si on veut entre guillemets ordinaire
que tout le monde peut emprunter
c'est pourquoi ça donne un côté 1 à la
manière d'un autre côté je le déplacer
au sol est parce qu il est maintenant
immortel
je ne fais pas de sculpture pour comme
mission je prends un missionnaire
je fais de la sculpture me faire plaisir
à moi même je me dis si je me fais
plaisir à moi il ya des gros chance
certain plaisir à d'autres